the money here. Yeah. Yeah, I'm seeing that. Yeah, cuz I I started
the stream probably I would say 90%
90% confident that uh Nick Dioro was doing it over emotion, but
then with numbers like that, I mean,
so I was listening to Dicker's coverage and I like asked him
a question and I'm just I'm literally not sure what's up like
what his opinion was on this moment. So, I'll play the moment
here while we're waiting for just a second and then >> the
dance.
>> You're all right, mate.
>> Uh, it's going well. You cut off there for a second.
What's up? >> Yeah. Um, >> I am.
What I was looking at? What I was looking at? Um, oh, it was
the clip that you sent me. Ethan has even outright lied in his
legal filings, incorrectly claiming that one of the Snark users
was a mod that was collaborating with Denims to steal his copyright.
In reality, this was just a regular subreddit user who sent Denims
a DM expressing that she should stream a reaction to the content
nuke to avoid giving Ethan views. She never even responded to
this message. Again, this is an instance of Nicholas blatantly
downplaying and not engaging with criticism against Ethan Klein.
He claimed that he would look into this if it was a lie, but
then never ended up following up. >> I think it's the Dan
Saltman tweet is the important one. I don't know if this is actually
a moderator. It seems like preliminary reporting is, yeah, this
is an H3 snark moderator. I don't know who this Dartis guy is,
and I don't know how they got that information. I feel like if
this is real, like not that, like
if it's real, cuz it's from the lawsuit. If this is actually
a moderator and that's actually the Discord tied to the moderator,
this is really bad for them. This would be really bad for them.
This is like
either absolutely nothing or a complete and total nuke.
I if that if that's a Reddit moderator, that's if that's a a
snark moderator. This is absolutely [__] worst case
scenario for Denim's mm probably.
I've heard privately from people and I'm not going to name any
names. They're they're skeptical about this. So, I'm proceeding
with caution, but I mean that's [__] that act would
be [__] crazy if it turns out to be fully >> Yeah.
Um, so Nick Yeah. Nick never goes back and clarifies that the
uh that the Snark Mod thing was
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But the way you you were talking about
it with the junk drawer again. I was just driving, so I was just
like, oh, it seemed like you were like, oh, I don't hold him
responsible for taking the lawsuit thing seriously. And it's
like, it doesn't seem like that was actually the case. That doesn't
even happen in the clip. Um, from the second he sees that, he
says, "No, this isn't real." He says, "According to the reporting,
at first he keeps trying to play it as like, oh, Dan Saltman's
only reporting this. It's only Dan Saltman reporting this." And
then eventually he's like, "Well, I guess that is the court documents."
And it's like clear, I don't know what date this is on, but it's
clear somebody told him, likely the Klein, that that person literally
wasn't a a Sark mod.
>> Um, I have to like I don't know exactly what nature
it was. The original the original Dan thing was uh December 16th,
>> Well, that came out. I want to say that came out with
the thing, right? But it would depend on when Nick's looking
at this. Oh, no, never mind. It says 16. >> Yeah, there's
a followup comment from
Yeah. Did I say something else? Yeah, 16th. There's a follow-up
from Dan underneath that says it was 6 hours uh 6 hours after
uh Nick was or 6 hours before Nick's looking at it. So, presumably
on the same day. Um, it seems >> Sorry, his uh No, his
um desktop says 16th. So 8:48 p.m. on the 16th.
So it's the same day. >> Oh, yeah. Yeah. >> So I'm
guessing >> I'm guessing somebody That's what's weird to
me is like it seems like they might have filed that paperwork
knowing full well that person was not a mod.
Somebody told Nick, "Hey, I'm resident [laughter] as a mod."
And he says, "I don't know. I literally don't know. I'm not going
to name names." So maybe it's not them. But somehow he knew even
though the court documents that dropped that day said it was
a mod, he knew to be like immediately reticent before he'd even
identified that it was the court docs he was looking at.
>> He did say that somebody was skeptical, so he's going
to take it with a grain of
>> What do you think? He just wants to believe that it
is. >> He's been told by people that he should be probably
skeptical about the claim and he wants to believe that it's like
huge to be able to like sell the narrative. That's the vibe that
I got. >> Did he run with the H3 mod thing? I was just
I was like, "Oh, you said he believed the court docks." And I'm
like, "I don't think he believed the court docs. I think he explicitly
didn't believe the court docs, which was weird given the court
docs had just dropped."
>> That was that was my like I noticed that when I read
this, the court docs had just dropped and somebody had told him
basically right after they dropped cuz I think um the person
who told you that it wasn't a mod is probably the person who
told me. I'm not sure that that was that day
and I'm not sure that somebody would have better knowledge than
that person.
Okay. What uh what person can you send me in DM? >> Kathy.
Talk about Kathy. I
>> Okay, never mind.
>> Yeah. Um presumably I don't think Nicholas Yuri would
be in contact with Kathy. Um that would be a huge reveal if Yeah.
I don't know who it would be though. Um >> do you think
that he's got No way. He's got a direct line with Ethan. He talks
all the time about >> I mean he absolutely he absolutely
has a direct line with Ethan in some way or another. But I just
I don't it doesn't even matter to me who um who he was talking
to. I just find it weird that somehow he knew before he even
looked at it. Like this is probably not real,
right? That's probably bad that they're filing court documents
when people are immediately like, "No, no, no, no. Don't run
with that. That's fake."
Yeah. I mean, that's possibly that's possibly true. I'm not
Yeah. Yeah. That's probably pretty bad. What my suspicion would
be is that it's somebody like Smaggle that's like because it's
like a drama thing going on right now. Somebody else has looked
into it and just said, "Hey, Nick, this might be like completely
[__] >> I doubt that it'd be somebody from
Ethan's side who would say, "No, actually, this is probably a
really weak point and we've probably lied here." I would massively
doubt that. Do you think that if Ethan Klein's lawyers were to
lie in court documents, Ethan would or somebody associate with
them like I don't know like Stariller AB would make a message
and say just FYI, we've lied here. Don't support us on stream.
>> No, obviously it wouldn't be that. It would be like
FYI,
um, we haven't totally validated this.
We're like pretty sure. We're like pretty sure, but we're not
100% sure, so maybe don't run with it is how I assume it would
be phrased. I It's not even that it would be them. That's not
really the big thing. I think it's crazy that he's going to look
at court documents that got dropped by Ethan Klein that day and
he's not going to make a big deal out of, well, people are telling
me this is not true.
Actual balanced analysis is people are already telling me this
isn't true. It's really weird that these people lied, but I'm
going to go ahead with the hypothetical that they didn't lie,
right?
That's just a that's a totally disingenuous place to launch the
the analysis from.
Um, it depend it depend massively on the contents of what was
said. So, for example, let's let's take there's two worlds here,
right? Smaggle has gone through and said, "By the way, Nick,
I've looked into the Denim's Discord. I've found this user. I've
found their Reddit account. I can see that they're not a mod.
I can see they're not a mod in like a snark discord or wherever
the I've looked for this person's other accounts.
He went live on stream. He spoke about it, you know, on and on
and on." Or somebody has said, "I don't know. I typed do toys
into Reddit. I can't see that he's ever posted on Snark. Maybe
he uses a different username. I can't verify this. >> Why
would just go with like the evidence they posted? So, this whole
all of this all of this begets like an analysis of the document
looking at like where where's the proof for that? They should
lay that out in the document, right?
>> Well, in the court filings.
>> Yeah. Shouldn't they say why they think he's a mod?
Isn't that where like the the unbiased like balanced analysis
comes from? >> They should say why they think he's a >> Um
I don't I mean this is what I this kind of goes to what I was
saying. If if you read something in a court filing probably take
it with a pinch of salt if it's like a big content creator and
they're probably putting things in court filings to like win
them PR points like Ethan Destiny. But I would probably assume
that especially on an incidental detail like that, I would probably
I would probably on balance just say, "Yeah, that's probably
true." If they're telling the court that for all the >> Hold
on. Hold on. >> Would you do that if you had somebody coming
to you going, "I don't think this is real.
>> I just depends on the content. >> I understand
where you're coming from.
>> It's the I'll give you the real I'll give you the real
answer for both of them. It's the difference between it's a balance
between the two >> telling me,
>> but it'd be it'd be if Babka came to me and said, "I
don't really know. I'm not sure about this. I've tried to have
a little bit of a look around and I can't really see anything
to verify it." Versus Quimman or I don't know, Aiden or Kathy
or you coming to me and saying, "This is fake. I've got all this
information. Tell me it's fake." >> Sure. Sure. Sure. If
So, I I agree with you.
Let me just ask you. Can you walk through if you that was the
case that somebody said like I can't find any evidence for this
kind of weird and you read that out on stream would you not like
think to go I just think any commentary YouTuber would do this
if you're streaming
grab me that document I just want to see what how they say it
how do they how do they show that
maybe Nick did that right maybe there's more to the stream here
and he actually goes through and checks it >> is that not
right cuz if basically if you get any credible thing that says
no you probably want to look and if If you don't get anything
credible, you probably don't say, "Well, I'm going to remain
skeptical of the literal court filings." Cuz he's remaining skeptical
of the literal court filings. So, he's assuming they're wrong.
So, I assume since Nick is not a that he's got good information
that leads him to believe that the court filing is wrong, or
else he probably wouldn't even really say it.
Uh I I can imagine Nick just trying to like cover his so if somebody
has said like h I haven't been able to verify this he's like
okay it even if this even if this is true this is big like essentially
just given like a big if true on stream um
>> I don't think
>> um I don't think Wait, ask me that again.
You don't think you would look at I I'm arguing that basically
if you were unbiased, if you're just trying to cover this stuff,
you would go, "Oh, well, I have two competing things here. One's
the court document. Obviously, they'll prove this out in the
court document. I'll just look for what their reasoning is."
And I do that on stream because I can just make more money on
stream covering it. But I don't think he wants to spend time
debunking anything Ethan claims on stream. And so he shies away
from the natural progress, the sorry, the natural progression
that you take on the stream.
>> I'm going to be especially for such a teeny tiny little
sideswipe. If Nicholas Curio actually thought that this was fake,
I don't think he'd ever have covered it on stream.
>> Well, I think two
he knows that you've got >> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
How could he not cover it?
>> How could he not cover it? It's literally in the filings
and they're all going, "We won."
>> Yeah, just don't just don't talk about the Dan Saltman
tweet or like the snapshot of the court filings. Like, don't
talk about any of that. Find another topic for the day. if he
genuinely thought that this was fake and information in there
was just a lie, just maybe like skip over it. Like what does
he what does he do about all of the about like, oh, what's the
fallout going to be? Um what's the precedent going to be legally
if these court cases actually go through to to a to a judgment
and he just says, "Oh, well, I assume they'll settle." Just completely
sidesteps it. I'd assume he'd do that if he knows that it's going
to be a negative influence for Ethan Klein. Just sidesteps the
issue. Doesn't engage with it.
really I maybe I to me it's just like you have basically somebody
telling you I don't think this is true and they filed it. Obviously
if they filed something that is just false that's bad,
Yeah. Of course.
Yeah. And I think that's the reason he doesn't I think that's
what he suspects here. I think he suspects that it's false which
is why he's saying I don't really want to look into it too much.
Right. Because of something somebody said to him. I'm guessing
he's looked into it a little bit himself and so he wants to cover
it without really like getting into it. And so he goes, "Well,
I think this is false." But there's no reason as somebody who
believes Ethan Klein's an honest actor to think this is false.
Right? They're literally claiming something in court filings.
Why would why would it be a lie?
Uh I don't know if it's just like a like a reflex for self-preservation.
Somebody's that you maybe trust has said, "I can't really like
find anything about this. This might not be true." Or you think
that, "Oh, they put it in a court document. Yeah, I'll probably
just say like this could be false. This could be false. I'm not
100% sure. But if this is big, if this is true, this is big.
>> Cuz the thing that I would criticize in this clip is
that Nick is clearly stretching his neck to find out or try to
argue that if this is big or if this is real, this is big. Cuz
if this is
>> arguably it goes the other way, right? Some H3 moderator
has reached out to Denims, but there's no response there. >> Denims
hasn't responded to them. So arguably, let's say that this is
let's say this is the only time that H3 moderators ever reached
out to Denims.
>> Seems like she's not interested in responding to them.
Or at the very least, it's kind of evidence against the fact
that there is actual collaboration given the fact that they add
them. If this is if this is part of a series of messages where
a bunch of H3 snark moderators are trying to contact Denims,
then this is unlikely to be the very very first one if it's part
of a series. So there's more and more evidence there that there
isn't collaboration between the Snark Mods and Denims. That's
the bigger thing there for me that Nick is kind of like bending
his neck to try and argue this is a great point against Denims
and the [__] moderators.
>> I don't think him trying to argue that like h is real
like playing about >> that doesn't really make any sense
to
>> No. Do you do you think that's possible that they would
have like a bunch more evidence of the Snark moderators talking
to Denims and in their filing where they're complaining about
the Snark moderator talking to Denims where they're saying it's
a Snark moderator, they don't include any of that evidence or
the back and forth. That like clearly makes their case. >> No,
no, that's my point. That's my point. So, I'm saying you've got
a you've got a a single sample. Let's say that it's the only
time it ever happened. The only time that H3 moderators ever
contacted Denims. In my opinion, it shows that Denims is airing
them. And in that view, Denim's never collaborated with them.
Let's say in another view, possibly maybe it's part of a series.
Well, it seems as though Denims have been ignoring these guys
for a certain amount of time. This is not going to be this is
unlikely to be the first time if it is part of a series. You
you know what I mean?
I understand what you mean, but then again, I just don't see
how that's possible in terms of like there's like a decision-making
tree that happens when Dan tweets here. I think Dan posts his
like best evidence in his thread. I don't think Dan if that stuff
exists. It's like >> just realistically if that stuff does
exist
it's in that thread, right?
I But it's I can see where you're coming from like hypothetically
if a whole bunch of things happen that are incredibly unlikely,
>> right? That are I I think are incredibly unlikely that
Dan left out the best piece of evidence of collaboration between
Denims and H3 Snark mods.
>> Yeah. like I [clears throat] >> clear what I'm
saying in the second part here is >> that Dorio is clearly
reaching for an argument and that it it clearly works the other
way. So my argument is that >> for sure >> this clearly
shows that there isn't collaboration but yeah so I agree with
you the fact that there isn't better evidence here is kind of
evidence to a certain degree after this much investigation
it is evidence of absence the fact that there's like absence
of evidence at this point cuz they've got an incentive to be
able to prepare that for the court right
>> yeah sure yeah I don't mean to even give you Dude I
was not really um I was literally driving around there's like
uh I I was literally driving around doing like errands and listening
to like in one ear while trying to figure out some other stuff.
So, it's like not even I didn't have like a serious criticism.
I was just like, "Oh, you said he took the he was just saying
the lawsuit was like honest." But I think he immediately was
like, "Oh, I don't think this is true." And I was like, "Oh,
that cuz that seemed like a weird thing to me that he looked
at the filings and first he was like trying to go, this is just
Dan Saltman." He was like, "As this is being reported." And then
he was like, "Wait, I can't really say as this is being reported
because this is technically the court document." I'm like, "Yeah,
it is. You have to take that. That's literally Ethan's word right
there. Like,
uh, >> well, this is the whole thing, right? Cuz it's not
it's not really Ethan's word. And this is why usually I would
probably like trust core documents cuz I would think if you're
Ethan's point of view or if you're a lawyer's point of view,
I understand adding things in, there's like a little bit of rhetoric,
a little bit of like flavor, but in the substance, the substance
that you're adding in there, are you really going to lie about
facts that are later going to be contested and just increase
your legal fees?
It's maybe gonna kind of
dude I think Ethan would
>> I think Ethan would think because realistically I think
even to to respond to this don't they basically have to reveal
themselves to some extent reveal a lawyer that they could be
subpoenaed through. But you're you are right that I said it's
Ethan's word. It's not Ethan's word. It's his lawyer's word.
>> Yeah.
Yeah. >> But I do I do think it's like clearly clearly
doesn't hold up to scrutiny >> like almost certainly just
false, right?
>> Like unless something >> Yeah. In retrospect >> crazy
comes out >> or even prospectively. I think
I do do you not agree with this that it seems as though the lawsuit
that's happening right now to try and prove some kind of collaboration
for the Snark mods. This is happening like on the fly. Like sure
it's filed and but like motions are being introduced to add in
more and more and more evidence as they try to go through. I
don't think they Yeah, I don't think they ever had any evidence
of this. I don't think this ever existed,
>> I don't Do you think
>> that the snark moderators are collaborating with people?
>> cuz I think Nick probably thinks it does >> Oh,
no. I don't think so. I I don't think so.
>> What? Because it would be incredibly It would be like
for denims. It would be incredibly stupid for her to respond
to these people, right?
>> Like in in general. Um maybe I I don't think he thinks
that that exists. I I've seen no evidence to suggest that it
exists,
right?
>> And I don't think Nick's the kind of guy who just on
vibes thinks things exist.
Uh if you take the view of denims and these other these other
like I guess like what like not really bread tube streamers but
like assan orbiters uh in Nick's mind don't forget Nick believes
that Casey Trron is a Hassan Orbiter. Okay, this is the mind
that we're dealing with. >> These people believe that Casey
Tron is an Assan orbiter. Um, so the fact that they would want
to have like an activist role in propping up snark to take down
the bad Zionist Ethan Klein, I think this is how people like
Dioro and Ethan fans think about uh, Denims, Casey Tron, people
like that, Frogen.
So I think on their view
would collaborate with Yeah,
>> I think that's the narrative that is
>> That's the narrative that Dioro is pushing forward.
Uh, unless you think Dioro is selling really.
>> Um, I I think Dioro is being I think that's his his
whole that's like the whole thing we're watching here is how
much will this guy debase himself like give up his former principles,
the things he used to hold on to like they were iron, okay? Like
like he used to hold on to these things, these principles about
how you basically handle information, how you make accusations.
He's the guy who wrote the rules and now he's not really following
any of his old rules.
That's like what the junk video is about, right?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Don't get me wrong. I Yeah, I agree with
that 100%. >> Talking about I think he still believes all
of those same things
>> and I don't know. I can't tell how much of it is emotional
for him to keep supporting Ethan versus how much of it >> he
just can see the dollar signs. I cuz trust me with the amount
of money he's making, I have some understanding of that. It's
really difficult to see things like in an unbiased way. Okay.
Yeah. What you talking about with like um time under the Destiny
orbit?
>> Yeah. So, I'm saying like the kick numbers I was getting
when I had like Dan Saltman on my stream trying to argue even
though me and Qu were like busting his balls the whole time.
The the money you were getting from that I was getting from that
was insane. So, I understand how you can like kind of let some
things slide. I get it.
>> Yeah. That's why I was like so forgiving of this guy
when he first started doing
>> That he's honest or that he's letting it slide because
of the money.
>> I think that for some of this stuff he's probably not
he's he's not going to [__] like rattle uh rattle
his sword or like ring the bell when he's got a disrupt with
Ethan. I think that he might just point out out every now and
again. Yeah, I thought I was Yeah, you know, I I kind of criticized
Ethan for that. But he's not going to make it like a big thing.
Like I think would >> but Ogie I don't so far as I am aware
doesn't try to like c relationships with like bigger streamers.
>> In fact actually that's not necessarily true. So he
will with he will with Nick
or will actually avoid talking about things that might embarrass
Nick or be critical of Nick. >> And I think that's the
exact same way that Dory operates with Ethan. I >> things
that would be embarrassing to Ethan. You're probably cow [clears throat]
away from >> but with Augie that's different
different um basis for that happening with with Nick. He literally
has a reason to hate Ethan Klein, right? >> Like he kind
of hated Ethan Klein or he had a a really negative opinion. Auggie
and Nick are friends and they've been friends for like a decade.
That's like a different basis the disingenuousness is coming
from. Right. And Auggie has criticized Nick far more than Nick
has ever criticized Ethan. Like Auggie went and debated it. It's
in the video obviously. So >> like Auggie, as much as it's
difficult to, you know, he's not going to go as hard as Queen
is obviously,
>> I I think for for them being friends for as long as
they have and that being like a big creator, he's kind of tied
to. I do think he went about as hard as could be expected reasonably.
And I don't think you would say the same for Nick >> with
some of Ethan's content. Okay. >> So, what I'm saying is,
okay, so the motivation is different and the degrees to which
they'll do it is different, but functionally what I'm talking
about is they'll kind of like ignore or pass over or not give
too much attention >> like an abstract concept that could
be the same. Sure.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. But that's what I'm pointing
to. So, in that same way, you really don't have an opinion on
whether it's emotional connection with Ethan or just following
the money. You don't have an opinion on that either. >> I
didn't say I don't have an opinion. I was like I asked what your
opinion was. I think it's the money like almost entirely. I don't
think it's an emotional connection.
That's my personal feeling.
>> But I like Sorry, there might be some mix there of like
the money
>> subconsciously
is causing it to feel like an emotional thing, but it's a totally
fake emotional thing that he would never apply anywhere else
where he wasn't getting like tons of money from this community.
>> Possibly because Yeah. being completely open. Let me
send you a link. I'm sure you've already seen the Freddy Woods
uh tweet, but I started the stream with a very very different
$18,000 in super chats this year. >> Okay. Even more than
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He he makes a lot of money here. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm seeing that. >> Yeah. Cuz I I started the stream
probably I would say 90%
90% confident that uh Nick Dioro was doing it over emotion. But
then with numbers like that, I mean, >> like here, I'll
I'll just show you >> probably more money than most creators
will ever make in their lifetime. >> I'll literally, and
I can say this, and I I understand why people think that this
is like um not like a big deal. I'll send you this.
This is from my kick dashboard. Okay,
this is like, okay, >> this is the this is the amount of
money I made
November 2024 on kick alone.
So, like I understand where Nick's coming from. I understand.
>> Wait, what? >> No, I'm joking. I'm joking video.
>> Yeah, I obviously sent it to you in DMs because I didn't
want that. Yeah. Okay, go.
But I understand where Nick's coming from and said like I understand
that there's like a monetary incentive that sort of changes it
affects your ability. But I was aware of that. I was honest with
people. I'm like there might be it might be that the money here
is like making me see things differently. Making me like not
analyze this 100% correctly,
Yeah, I do.
Yeah, I do get that. Okay,
I kind of see in a different direction then. All right. Maybe
maybe
I just I maybe I would need to think on it more. Um for me, it's
like a like big speculator thing trying to figure out exactly
where somebody else's headsp space is. >> It um >> it
basically doesn't matter because the the effects are the problem,
right? His motivations don't cause the issue. It's the effects
of the bias that makes like the issue exist, right? So, for us,
we can speculate on the on why it happens. It doesn't really
change anything except maybe whether or not you you like like
Nicholas as a person, but [clears throat] honestly,
I I don't care. I I thought Nicholas was a cool guy when I hung
out with him, but he just like I think I think this has gone
too far with the the Ethan stuff, but not really. I don't know.
I don't even
it's difficult to to express if he hadn't done the whole thing
with Queenman if he wasn't supporting Willie Mack. That's more
where my annoyance comes from, right? Where that's like obviously
just totally disingenuous. The Ethan stuff is a violation to
me of his principles. But it's like more understandable. The
Queen and Willy thing where he like retweets the Willy Mac video,
leaves it up for days, and then refuses to acknowledge that Willy
Mack just blatantly lied. >> The truth is bad empanada
did not originate my docs. He maliciously spread it everywhere.
But my docs originated on a niche form by this guy's unhinged
viewers. So when I see this clip, it's obviously a dog whistle
to [__] with me. He literally gets a donation that
says, "I understand what we must do." Wink wink. Anything is
justifiable against Destiny and the people who support him. No.
Is that not the standard? That's That's what he's laying out
for me here. Now, I have principles. I have principles. I don't
think it's no bad tactics, only bad targets. That's not >> As
he's literally showing my docs, Destiny is very clearly laying
out that those are the standards that he believes in. Those are
the standards he he wishes to be enforced. Is if you're a doctor,
if you call for violence, anything is justifiable against you
supporters. >> Order taken. >> Okay, that's not what
I'm saying, Max. Actually, I just explicitly said otherwise.
Actually, Max, >> he's got a [__] eating grin
on his face. He knows what he's doing. This then gets retweeted
by his friend Jtock, who pushed the exact same narratives about
me. I'm obviously very unhappy about this. it's affecting my
real life. But instead of anyone actually acknowledging this,
they do what Bad Empanada did and try to hypocrisy hunt to justify
their >> And Willie Mac's basis for ascribing this to me
now
is a clip that takes place and purely, you can see this from
the video, it makes no sense otherwise.
A clip that takes place weeks after Willie has already been doxed.
He
uses that to claim that I am the one doxing him or that my fans
are the ones doxing him. And that necessarily has to be the case
because in the clip uh Willie Max's talking about I'm reacting
to a Destiny quote tweet of Gate Fumodor and this Gate Fumador
person posted a video a clip of bad empanadas video of uh of
Willie Max Dogs. I don't watch Bad and Panada. I'm not a big
bad empanada viewer. So, I hadn't seen this video in full. I
didn't know the contents of of this clip um intimately. And it
is partly blurred. It is partly blurred at one point. And the
docs does not appear until like a minute, 2 minutes into the
clip. So, it plays silently while I'm discussing it. Obviously,
I knew what the clip was about because I mean, everyone was talking
about how Willie Mack had been doxed. So, I was
aware
of sort of what was happening. But the clip plays on my stream
and this this um you know dogs information
scrolls by while I'm making a point. Now in Willy's own video,
Willie says he does not blame Destiny because by the time Destiny
quote tweets his docks, it's already viral.
It's already broadly seen. So, I am absolutely
baffled how I am supposed to have any responsibility when the
quote tweet I am covering to make my point about Destiny already
has like a 100,000 200,000 views when I'm looking at it and I
have a few hundred live and then I censor it for the the VOD
upload because obviously I don't intend to dox Willy Mac. So,
I censor it for the VOD upload. >> They're like, "Why aren't
you mad at Destiny? He quote tweeted your docs, >> Why
aren't you mad at Destiny himself? >> Destiny is defending
my already viral docs that's already in the hands of all the
people who hate me. We're acting like context and scale don't
matter. >> So, a few hundred people saw this through my
stream when hundreds of thousands have already seen it through
Destiny's video. Yet, Willie Mack uses that logic to absolve
himself
of any culpability in JTalk stocks because Destiny or Destiny's
fans had already posted it with hundreds of thousands of
But for some reason, this logic that Willie Mack uses to absolve
himself
doesn't apply to me. >> The Queen and Willy thing where
he like retweets the Willy Mac video, leaves it up for days,
and then refuses to acknowledge that Willy Mack just blatantly
lied.
Um, that's so much worse to me. That's so so so much worse to
me. And also, Willie was lying about like Auggie, too.
Like I thought that was where I was like, "Okay, Nicholas is
totally gone. That's I'm going to be to be completely upfront.
I My problem is I've got like a deep um I don't know if it is
like an intuition, but like a gut feeling. I want to assume that
people are operating in good faith, people are being honest,
and this is what people like genuinely feel like." Um, so when
people go go and like delve into like, okay, this person is lying,
this person is being deceptive, manipulative, and here's the
reason why, I kind of I don't know, like my gut is pulling against
me in those kind of arguments cuz I want to assume that people
are being in good faith. >> Um, but I am arguing that it's
kind of subconscious with the money. Sorry. I do I do think he
like for all intents and purposes if you got him like a load
in a room and we're just asking him questions about this. I do
think he'd say the same things he's saying on stream cuz he's
it's not it's not like in his active thought process. Sorry,
go ahead. I cut you off.
No, no, that's right. Um with the Willie Mack thing though, that
is slightly different. I feel as though Nick hates Queeman and
he's just seen that Willie is like actually going after him and
maybe feels as though I don't like Queman's like dug his own
grave or something like that. He's happy to like [__]
buried. >> Wait, no, no, no. Queen's [laughter] his friend.
Queen was the last friend he was making in 2024.
>> Last internet friend. Last internet >> I forget.
>> Yeah, last internet friend. His friend.
>> It was a
throughout 2020.
It was throughout 2024.
>> because we the black stuff. It was a little earlier
with the mama stuff as well. Yeah. >> I mean, it would
have been a little bit into 2025. I think Nick was still in the
Discord and hanging out with us after streams in 2025, but sure,
it would have been mostly 2024.
>> They developed that relationship.
>> Yeah. But I I do feel as though the Willie Mack thing
was just he could have he could have said a lot more about it
very very easily. probably without causing that much upset to
Willie. Um I mean I I pointed out earlier. Are you gonna go through
the video or have you already done that? I I reacted to it blind
last night, which was I think a mistake because there's a lot
of supplementary info I would have liked to include if I had
gone over it today, but I just went over it blind. And >> did
you notice >> Yeah, I agreed with decent amount of it.
>> Reaction to the Willie Mac Show video. And especially
in retrospect, the Tommy would say before prefacing his support
was so much harsher than Nick ever was about the Willy Mac Show
video. It was >> I didn't
>> I didn't notice it, but yeah, that's because Nick refused
to comment. Basically, Nick is just like, "This is stupid interpersonal
drama." It's like, "No, it's not. You You upload You up Sorry,
you retweeted a video with blatant lies in it. You put your stamp
on that. It's not personal drama. You put your professional stamp
on that video. It's not even up for debate, right?" He calls
it petty personal drama and just dips out of commenting, which
is insane. So yeah, Tommy does by virtue of making any comment,
Tommy is harsher because Tommy can't look like a total, right?
Can't say nothing was wrong. >> Yeah, Tommy was prepping
it with like, "Willie might have completely this up. Will he
might have completely mismanaged
but I'm still on that guy's side 100%."
I feel like that is probably what Nick would say if given the
chance. But yeah, um especially with how like wretched the winning
match was. Uh maybe maybe I'm personally biased cuz I was involved.
That could weigh into it. But I feel like the Woody M show was
like so egregious and so baseless. >> I think I don't know
how you can not comment on that >> if you care at all about
self-p policing. You don't have to be the guy to take him out.
You don't have to be the guy to put him down, but to like comment
substantially on it to some degree a little bit.
>> Yeah. Yeah, >> I don't know how you avoid it.
>> You would think [snorts]
or I showed this on stream yesterday, but uh like Willie on the
day that uh Cherry made some posts, okay, he DM' me. I don't
know if I showed you this before, but he DM'd me to like laugh
at me. It's like Cherry was posting about how she was
I showed this on stream, so you can show it if you want, but
Cherry posted that she was like
and he messaged me to like laugh about it. I'm just like, "Dude,
are you you're like ill." And obviously that same day he retweets
like Destiny about stuff. He's like talking about how I'm like
the worst person. So it's not like somebody said, "Oh, do you
think he's reaching out in good faith?" No, that's a DM, by the
way. He DM'd me about it.
I'm just like, dude, this guy
guy's a [__] weirdo.
Content is not visible in my region. Okay, I'll have to read
this out real quick. So Cherry says, "My life is humiliating
and worthless. No, no, no, no, no. You don't have to read the
whole thing. Just show the image. Sorry. I don't want to. >> I
don't want to read the whole thing on stream. I just personally
don't. Okay. >> Does it Does it seem as though I can? Um,
okay. I like I'm trying to open it up some way somehow.
>> Wait, what? You can't open the image? You can't open
like an image or link. >> I don't I don't I don't know
why it says it's not available in my region. I'll just I'll put
>> I think it got nuked in the UK because of uh Well, >> I
just I I resent it as a an attachment. >> It's for children.
Okay. It's for children. Nice. Okay, there we go. >> Not
nice, but
>> Yeah. Yeah. >> Sorry. I literally You can read
it if you want. I'm just going to mute. I I hate litigation.
>> No, it's fine. I'm not going to mute. I'm not I'm not
going to I'm not going to Don't worry about it. It's okay. >> Yeah.
Yeah. That's pretty uh That's pretty harsh. That's uh that's
pretty mean. Yeah. Yeah. It's just [__] It's just
weird to me that No, it's like not mean. It's just like weirdly
psychopathic given like I don't understand what I did to generate
that much hatred from him. I actually don't
like I >> I understand he thought maybe my criticisms were
a little harsh, but like this all is downstream of one conversation
we had on a stream. >> I just don't understand how you
could be that that much later,
>> especially five hours ago. Yeah. um
5 hours after like presumably situation still ongoing. I could
try and check. I don't know what my DMs with Willie were like
um during the whole doxing thing.
Dude, those were like really weird. Like I think I was um I think
I was just DMing him to clarify stuff. He like get a job you
loser. Get a job you loser. like, okay, you're like a wretched
f slur, like maliciously lying, and you know, you're maliciously
lying, and then I try because I think that it's a misunderstanding
to say FYI, this and
[__] Um, have I still got them? He did that. >> He
did that thing on Twitter. >> I feel like >> where
you like soft block somebody,
>> you message somebody block and you get the follow.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Oh yeah. >> Yeah. Okay. I don't
want to leak these actually. I sound hinged. Um cuz I stop making
jokes about his wife's
um but okay. I'll probably send this to you later. Maybe see
what you think. But
>> yeah. All in all, Willy's probably a wretched c and
Nick shamelessly back him
I mean, if I'm going to give him like if I if I'm just going
to dispassionately analyze what I think is going on, he sees
it as like people coming for his job and he's going to go after
them with anything and he thinks they're going after him with
anything. And so he thinks like everybody on our side is like
gunning for him, gunning for his career. And so when Destiny
meages messages him and is like, "Look, these guys are like doxing
you." He's just 100% primed to believe that, right? But it's
it's really like it just comes from a misunderstanding of how
stream content works versus like video content. Like he expects
to be basically giving kid gloves in any real-time conversation,
right? Like the conversation I had with him, the conversation
Que
and I go at each other that hard like randomly on a stream on
a Tuesday where we're like literally just like either yelling
at each other talking. It's like that was nothing. And I think
he thought that was like we were trying to like set him up to
to his career or something. It's like, dude, that was just random
And I think that random banter got turned into like, oh, this
is a genuine concerted effort to kill this guy. >> And
it really wasn't.
I don't I don't know. >> That's how I see it. Is he actually
What's going on there? Is that he actually perceives it as malicious
or he feels like I don't know, he got completely wrong. >> I
think he absolutely
hate how Tommy talks about it, >> right? Isn't it Isn't
all the proof you need for that? And how Tommy talks about it.
Tommy and Willie, I feel like, talk a lot. And Tommy was leaking
a whole bunch about their mentality, right? They thought it was
totally malicious.
Chud was talking about [__] >> Yeah. When When
Chud was talking about that's like totally malicious, trying
to take people down. >> Yeah. 100%.
>> Um I [laughter] even I do think they see that. said
several times, "If you want to know what Nick thinks and you
want to know what Willie thinks and you don't want know you want
to know what Turkey Tom thinks, just see what Tommy says when
he's had a a couple becks in him." I'd never considered that
though. Yeah. That probably also comes from Willie as
>> Yeah. So I like And it really wasn't. And I tried to
at the time So I I used to be like you. I just assume like good
faith from other people at the time. I tried to talk to Nick.
Nick said he would talk to me and then he just decided he wasn't
going to. I was literally going to be like, "Hey, I went a little
too hard on Willie. I, you
I maybe was a little too aggressive. I talked over him a little
bit." I probably said, you know, some stuff about, "Oh, you you
could come to me for like criticisms and and that was stupid.
I should have just said like you go to Queen." You could literally
just go to any third party source who had covered it and they
would probably like help you in some way, right? That's what
I wanted to say to Nick. I didn't want to go after Willie and
like really prove out the argumentation. I was just like, "Oh,
I think you guys see this the wrong way." Never got a chance
to do that. And then it turned into this whole thing. I think
it's silly that it turned into like a whole thing where
I don't know, everybody's like feuding over this. Didn't have
to.
>> That's how I personally feel about it. At this point,
I mean, Willie Mack forever, but
for Nick, I'm I'm like still at the point where I'm like, "No,
Nick could be redeemed totally." Like, in my eyes.
>> I said that. I said that earlier. I said that earlier.
I think Ethan unironically gets snarked to death. The war is
over. Um, Hassan won. And then Nick will move to something else
and then he'll be redeemed. He'll be off the Ethan train. >> He
can go back to like I don't know who do we want him to follow
next. Who do we want him to be parasoially motivated by >> We've
got to find somebody better. We got to find like
YouTube drama. >> It's all Han is bad. It's all Han. No,
no, no. It's all Han is bad.
That's
which is shocking given like obviously we talked about this on
stream on my stream a lot. I don't know about your stream, but
like while we're talking about while we've been talking about
how anti-semitic Twitch is, how anti-Semitic Hassan is, Nick
Fuentes has gone from like literally 3,000 average viewers to
50,000 average viewers,
>> As we're talking about how anti-Semitic the entire left
is, Nick Fentes has built an empire in that like 15 to 18 months.
It's crazy. Aspen Gold already had an empire, built up his empire
even further, and it's like, well, at some point hopefully people
realize >> there's bigger demons out there to
Motivated. So, >> it's like a similar point in a different
vein. Like all the Diorio fans or realistically all the he Ethan
Klein fans that like cry about anti-semitism
like truly do not give a about a single other like iota of kind
of racism or any kind of injustice but they'll never talk the
same way about that they do with like I don't know Latinos
like while Trump is just deporting possibly citizens or people
who've lived in the United States their entire life. literally
[snorts] ICE being given the go-ahhead by the Supreme Court to
just like take people off the street, take them away, [laughter]
ship them off to a different country, and explicitly allowed
to profile them because they are
but there's nothing. There's nothing cuz it's just like a I don't
know. Is is it like a is is anti-semitism
now a code word to give your support for the H3 podcast?
I feel unironically online in online spaces, I feel like it's
come down to that. Nobody else gives a [__] about
any other racial group. >> I don't know. I'm trying to
think of
I So I cover like a lot of politics so I don't see it the same
way. There's like a there's like an overarching thing that exists
that's like Israel Palestine that's above even the Hassan Ethan
like destiny stuff. It's like it's above that. So I see it as
like Israel stuff. I see it as connected to like Israel and pro-
Zionism versus just being like anti-semitism to protect Nick.
So I I don't see that as much, but like I could I could see what
you're saying. Like I could see the possibility of that. I just
don't see it through the like commentary focused lens.
>> Well, you can go through it from the other side. How
much do you see people complaining that people are painting all
Muslims as terrorists?
>> Cuz that's
sure. Exactly. Exactly. Exactly. That's that's sort of more what
I'm saying is I don't see it through the lens of like the H3
stuff. It's like when somebody's complaining about anti-semitism,
I commented that like you you got to see this this dog whistle
pseudo dog whistle in North American politics where people talk
about getting moral clarity. We can't support Nick Fentes. We
need moral clarity. And I'm like, as soon as you say the words
moral clarity, that's actually just oh, anti-semitism. It's like
a new word for anti-semitism. I know you're about to go on a
rant about Fuentes and Tucker Carlson and all of this other [__]
right? And yeah, it's like it's
es especially disingenuous from Republicans and like Ben Shapiro
because you support a whole bunch of people who other minority
groups constantly.
Yes, the exact thing you're talking about. You you're willing
to totally other Muslims, you're willing to totally other Latinos,
but now that Jews are being otherred, you're like, "Oh, this
is actually really bad. Racism is really bad." Remember how you
guys all hate racism? like uh do they do they remember? I don't
know if they remember.
>> yeah, maybe I find it slightly more acceptable like
the hypocrisy if it's part of like a coherent all-encompassing
political ideology or political worldview. But the point that
it just like you will find >> Wait, it's not coherent though.
It's not coherent. It's literally not coherent. >> You
look at Ben Shapiro explaining why he's like never Trump. No,
no, no. He explains exactly why he's never Trump in 2015 when
he decides he's not going to vote for Trump. Every single criticism
he made is exactly who Trump is now. And he sucks Trump off now.
Like it's it's not even internally coherent. It doesn't make
any sense for them to they they think they're like, "Oh, the
left are the real racists cuz they try to do like DEI and it's
not even internally coherent. It's complete garbage." Like top
to bottom. Ben Shapiro is like the worst human being on earth.
Ben Shapiro is a worse human being than Nick Fuentes. It's not
close. It's not close. Ben Shapiro is a worse person. Okay, it's
not close. And nobody will acknowledge that. Nobody can acknowledge
that. And I, by the way, at least 6 million people died in the
Holocaust. The Holocaust is real. Nick Fentes is just a less
bad person than Ben Shapiro. Ben Shapiro decided to put his people,
you know, proverbally on the cross for money. He's the worst.
Okay, he took somebody who was going to buy into all of the stuff
who was super protectionist going to buy into all of the, you
know, that his audience would would inevitably buy into all of
the, you know, anti-semitic canards that exist. And he decided
he's going to take some money in exchange and and let other people
give those opinions. So, he built a network of people who would
build up the exact kind of conspiratorial thinking that gets
used against. And then
he collected a paycheck and then he complains that they now hate.
It's like, no, you built this, Ben. You built the
Sorry, that's a whole rant on something else that I don't think
your audience cares about. But >> no, it's just interesting
you say that Ben Shapiro is uh [laughter] >> worse than
Nick Fuentes and then try and like get me to believe that you
actually think that 7 million 8 million people died in the Holocaust.
Um I said >> just kind of, you know, >> for those
with ears to hear and I to see that's all I'm going to say. >> Yeah,
I said six. I didn't I didn't do the thing where you get to like
build up the number to try to pretend it didn't happen, right?
I didn't do the Fentes thing on Piers Morgan. I said six. No,
I I believe the number that is reported historically at least
six, but that's fine. That's fine. Um >> Yeah, I said at
least >> we all heard it. >> Yeah. Yep. Um what I
was saying is like >> when it comes to like I don't know
like political ideologies. I feel like that's like more understandable.
Like you buy into a certain like political
fascination. There's a certain interest there. Um, I just I just
can't believe that for some people their like ideology,
the way that they like or the lens they perceive the world in.
I get it if it's conservatism. I even get it if it's like TPUSA
conservatism, but like Ethan Klene and the H3 podcast has changed
the way that you see racial prejudice in America.
I that's just bizarre to me. That that to me is like particularly
bizarre, but for maybe not like a completely articulable reason.
Maybe I just find it more pathetic that you bought into >> literally
only one group of people that has changed for >> a guy
and his horsefaced horsefaced wife just as much as the average
person buys
>> civic society.
>> Uh Lav weighed in on that. She said Ela Klein is beautiful.
Okay. Ela Klein is beautiful. She glows. She is radiant.
Is she
>> I do believe so. Yes.
>> Yeah. Okay. Okay. Yeah. Might be uh I mean, we're talking
about conflict of interest earlier with Nick Dioro and the money
he's making. >> Wait, are you surpris
where the win? >> Oh boy.
>> I'm just asking questions. >> To be clear, I I
believe it's Salt Lake City or somewhere. No, Chicago. I can't
even remember anymore. I'm going to say that Laplon travels at
least as far as Salt Lake City for holiday. Okay.
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. >> Are you saying
she holidays in Tel Aviv? Is that what you're saying right now?
>> Uh, you know, around that. That would be That would
be further than Salt Lake City. No,
>> that would be further. Yeah, that would be slightly
more >> than Salt Lake City.
>> I'm going to uh I'm going to leave you alone. [laughter]
Have fun with your stream, dude. I've probably got a little bit
>> Yeah. Yeah. I'll talk to you soon. We'll talk to you
later. Fun. Yeah. See you. Bye. Wow.